bonjour bonjour mesdames bonjour
messieurs
donc je suis photojournaliste
indépendant et depuis depuis à peu près
20 enfin j'ai fait une trentaine de
reportage dans une trentaine de pays
j'ai travaillé en tant que grand
reporter en afghanistan au pérou
cambodge au congo en france bien sûr
évidemment j'ai une passion pour
l'information
moi mon grand dada dans la fosse et la
géopolitique
je suis très près aussi la question des
droits humains ici et là la politique
française évidemment la culture un peu
souvent en cachette le sport c'est
formidable aujourd'hui parce que on a
les grands médias télé la radio la
presse écrite et presse écrite mais on a
aussi tout un tas de médias alternatifs
qui pousse sur internet on arrive à
trouver tout un tas d'infos de tous les
côtés fassent et c'est vraiment
formidable comme tout ça quand on veut
être informé savoir un peu comment ça
tourne vous suivez vous aussi un petit
peu l'info ou voit pas mais vous
informer a minima quand même mois sur et
non pour j'ai peur pour vous en tout cas
on va considérer qu ici on essaye un peu
quand même d'être des gens informés
alors dans cette information en fait moi
je vous avoue pour avoir beaucoup voyagé
je vois pas comment c'est possible de
comprendre le monde dans lequel on vit
si on ne va pas chercher des
informations
c'est tellement à la fois complexes
cette espèce de grand échiquier
international et national est tellement
petit aussi c'est tout riquiqui on le
voit dans l'actualité enfin les gens de
partout sont devenus nos voisins de
palier donc je vois pas comment on peut
ne pas comment comprendre ce monde sans
aller chercher l'info donne un exemple
c'est la politique la politique
française
on a des politiques qui sont devenus
deux des as mais admirables de la
communication qui sont capables quand
ils partent dans une phrase en cachant
soigneusement ce qu'ils veulent pas
qu'on sache et puis en mettant en avant
ce qui vont enfin voilà on n'arrive plus
à rien savoir rien comprendre à la fin
je vois pas comment sans information
sans aller chercher cette info on peut
arriver à comprendre
quelles sont les causes de leur décision
quelles sont les conséquences de leurs
décisions ou les conséquences de leur
demander cision je vais plus loin vois
pas comment on peut voter dont sa forme
pas c'est juste un exemple parmi
d'autres aussi vous me suivez ce que
vous êtes d'accord il faut être informé
pour comprendre un peu comment ça marche
a minima au moins ce monde compliqué
super je fais ma deuxième clic et je
reviens en arrière je vais pousser plus
loin mon raisonnement
en fait cette information paquet
d'années maintenant je traîne là dedans
sauf que ça a une autre vertu
ça nous pousse à réfléchir à penser tout
le temps à aiguiser notre explique
rythmes ska esprit critique
à part recevoir des fois on reçoit les
infos va dire non là c'est trop
simpliste c'est pas possible il faut que
j'aille voir plus loin et puis on va
chercher plus loin des fois on a des
doutes
on a des certitudes et qui deviennent
des doutes et puis en poussant plus loin
ça devient d'autres doute été au bout
des douze stades bien d'autres
certitudes
moi je sais pas vous mais je sais pas
combien de fois j'ai changé d'avis sur
des trucs que je ne connaissais pas ou
sur lequel j'avais une idée préconçue
à force d'aller chercher de l'info voilà
je trouve qu'on s'imprègne comme ça on
grandit on évolue en fait par rapport à
certains à cette info vous suivez encore
ok super donc là on a de la chance
globalement même si le dernier petit oui
a été un peu petit on est entre gens qui
nous informons en tout cas à peu près on
a conclu que c'était important pour
comprendre le monde de s'informer et
puis on a compris aussi que s'informer
ça pouvait nous permettre de grandir
d'évoluer super pas top en fait en fait
vous et moi on a un gros problème avec
cette information on nous cache des
choses
alors je vous rassure je vais pas partir
dans un énième débat sur le complot des
médias qui serait fomenté par les
illuminati ou je sais pas quoi
j'ai pas trop tu délires d'adolescents
j'ai malheureusement passé l'âge depuis
longtemps et puis je connais trop le
monde des journalistes
et j'insiste on a un souci on a un
problème il ya tout un pan de
l'information on reçoit pas il ya tout
un pan de l'information donc l on va pas
pouvoir aller puiser pour s'enrichir
sur la terre un peu plus 50% de la
planète 50% de la population ce sont des
femmes et un proverbe chinois à l'orge
enfonce une porte ouverte à givet on y
va tout entier au marché chinois il dit
les femmes portent la moitié du ciel
superman dans la formation les dames et
messieurs bienvenue dans le monde des
femmes invisibles pas un ange et
j'exagère un peu c'est un peu grossier
le trait est un peu trop fort bienvenue
dans le monde des femmes presque
invisible et puis si elles ne sont pas
invisibles
bienvenue dans le monde de la facilité
et bienvenue dans le monde du cliché
j'ai pris quelques exemples pour
illustrer ce propos commence avec la
presse economics en la matière je vous
assure c'est vraiment la meilleure
capital accession parle de pognon parle
de business un sérieux on va quand même
pas laisser on va se garder ça entre
nous pour l'expansion autres magazines
économiques avec cet écrit au dessus le
magazine qui donne du sens à l'économie
est clair grands dossiers sur les
nouveaux libéraux des gens qui créent
des chaussures des idées en fait sur le
libéralisme on regarde de près qui sont
ils
rauf on a trouvé une été trop vite on a
trouvé une femme chouette on a notre
alibi on est peinards n'en a fait un
truc de la semaine dernière on a pris
les coupes du monde tout simplement tous
les jours les pauvres du monde la
semaine passée enfin quotidien
exceptionnellement beaucoup de chance en
france d'avoir ce quotidien qui est une
référence internationale n'est pas le
cas dans tous les pays pour les coupes
du monde la semaine passée 80 sujet en
une sur les 80 74 qui présente des
hommes rtl y'a pas longtemps avec un
sujet plus lourd lits et d'un français
sur cinq a déjà été victime de
harcèlement sexuel dont la vérité elle
est quand même beaucoup plus disparates
d'un côté on a un français sur 20 à peu
près puis le côté on a une français sur
trois une française sur cap
mais la faute aux cartes et elle a
choisi pour illustrer ce propos c'est
une photo d'une femme qui est dans le
rôle de la prédatrice la presse
quotidienne régionale
franchement la matière je sais pas si à
mieux que je lis encore auch
elle meurt poignardé dans un drame
passionnel fait divers
à marseille quand il ya des règlements
de comptes entre les bornes et qui a une
personne qui est tué par une autre là
c'est un problème de société
par contre en france où les deux jours
et demi une femme meurt sous les coups
de son conjoint c'est un fait divers
et puis et puis c'est un drame
passionnel
je sais pas si vous avez la passion là
dedans ou de l'amour
moi je vois surtout de la haine et je
vois quelque chose de l'ordre du
professionnel je possède l'autre et
shuma chose 120 dans ses pages web
drame hoyé drame et un mot dans le
dictionnaire ces meurtres
c'est un meurtre aux cessionnaires ça
change un peu le sache quand même la
presse féminine pas gentil de presse
féminine en ce moment en europe pendant
un problème on a un problème avec des
conservateurs de tous poils qui poussent
un peu partout qui remettent en cause un
certain nombre de droits et notamment
les droits des femmes et en particulier
le droit à l'ivg est attaqué de partout
et puis à des pays en europe
juste à côté les femmes n'ont même pas
ce droit
ou alors de façon extrêmement limité bas
les mêmes conservateurs les mêmes ils
sortent du bois et puis essaye de
limiter encore ce champ là où l on voit
une formidablement de bonne journaliste
il fait un formidable reportage sur les
femmes en pologne dit lutte contre
l'atteinte fait à ce droit on court on a
un spécial beauté prendra 26 pages et on
a ce reportage qui comprendra quatre
questions de priorité évidemment vsd
il fait un truc sur le sport et la web
bizarre étrange une femme en une truc
sur le sport pour les 24 heures du mans
enfin il est passé sur qu'elle va avoir
de la peine à passer pour quelqu'un de
sérieux puis de thé 24 heures avec ce
genre de conte saveurs pas être vraiment
facile revient à notre propos de départ
là vous vous dites orient cqm et enfin
c'est grossier ils exagèrent des femmes
on en voit à la télé paris déjà pu même
dans les infos dont vous doutez vous
avez raison il faut douter pour mettre
en cause et c'est tout ce que je suis en
train de vous montrer c'est juste fait
pour illustrer de façon un peu de rôles
gens je le concède
des choses qui sont mesurées mesurée par
l'observatoire mondial des médias qui
intervalles réguliers nous donne des
chiffres soit sur la place des femmes
dans l'information ces chiffres et voici
dont 76% des cas la personne dont il est
question dans l'information
un homme dans la presse écrite c'est
même 79% et là je vais m'intéresser à la
petite dame qui est en colère à côté on
va regarder quand on parle d'elle
comment on parle d'elle tout haut ce
mode on coupe en quatre ans dans un
quart des cas quand on parle d'elle on
va parler d'elle dans un rôle différent
elle va être évidemment la mère de
monsieur truc la femme de monsieur
machin la fille de monsieur bidule elle
va être présenté dans quelques métiers
mais pas trop quand même injuste
vraiment les métiers de nana quoi et
puis bien sûr il ya la mode les
fashionistas et c'est un quart des cas
deuxième car on touche plus à
l'actualité internationale
la femme victime la guerre c'est quoi
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur ces terrains
la femme donc dans les médias ça va être
un mec avec un flingue et une femme en
pleurs dans les décomptes de ces maisons
point final fermer le manque uniquement
sa troisième car enfin on arrive dans
une zone intéressante et femmes
agissante des femmes en mouvement les
femmes politiques ont un peu droit au
chapitre aujourd'hui chez nous elles ont
un peu de rose chapitre parce qu'elle
pousse des coups de très forts reprendre
leur place
il faut qu'elle l'époux qu'elle pose des
poutres encore plus fort parce qu'on est
quand même encore loin de la parité mais
elles ont un peu de rose chapuis
on a ses spécialités en france on a
plein d'autres choses
c'est des gens qui se réunissent qu'ils
savent des sachant qu'ils échangent
bombe à ces sachants quatre invités sur
cinq
évidemment c'est des zones avoir une
experte une experte en géopolitique du
moyen-orient
une experte qui connaît en économie on
va inviter une experte parce que là on a
un problème sur la parentalité
on va vite et l'expert parce qu'on va
parler des métiers du soin d affirmer qu
il reste enfin tout ce que je vous dit
en fait on va se dire ouais mais c'est
fichu ces fichus parce que internet
génial effectivement dans les chiffres
que je viens de vous donner
internet n'est pas content et ça se
focalise uniquement sur la presse écrite
la radio et la télévision internet est
tellement vaste on peut pas raconter
par contre il ya eu des sondages de fait
par ci par là
tous ces sondages vont dans la même
direction si on inclut internet je suis
en train de vous expliquer les chiffres
que je vous ai donné
ils sont tous bien pire donc en fait je
reviens à mon raisonnement début pensé
est ce que j'ai compris moi dans l'info
j'ai d'abord compris que les femmes
étaient secondaires secondaire et puis
souvent liés à leur mari j'ai compris
que les femmes
il ya des fashionistas la mode c'est les
soldes c'est vachement futile en fait
tout ça quoi qu'est ce que j'ai compris
à j'ai compris aussi que les femmes
étaient des êtres faibles des victimes
en puissance a protégé par mois le mec
surpuissant le mâle protecteur faut
quand même un peu de testostérone
dans cette histoire là j'ai compris que
les femmes politiques aussi prenez un
peu d espace mais par contre souvent
avec des comportements à leur égard des
questions à leurs égards qu'on n'oserait
même pas imaginer vis-à-vis d'un homme
politique et les autres alors
les autres c'est qu'ils portent la
moitié du ciel du proverbe tout ce
qu'elle réalise tout ce qu'elles font
tout ce qu'ils imaginent tout ce
qu'elles créent et où la façon dont
elles résistent pourtant elle milite
ont-elles reconstruisent sait où leurs
performances au niveau managérial dont
des chefs d'entreprise leurs
performances professionnelles leurs
performances sportives
les scientifiques c'est où pourquoi je
n'ai pas accès à ça pourquoi tout ce pan
d'information ne me vient pas pourquoi
ça représente des cacahuètes dans
l'information
pourquoi on me prive mohamed nana on
s'en fout mais pour qu'on nous prive de
toute l'inspiration qu'on pourrait
prendre de ce qu'elles font
et puis c'est sûr que à côté de ça au
delà de ça ben moi je risque pas de
changer quand même
admettons je suis un chef d'entreprise
du chef d'entreprise et j'ai des
employés avec la presse et qu il ya
quand même vachement peu de chances que
je comprenne
j'ai intérêt à embaucher des femmes ok
il ya les grossesses
ok il ya les congés parentaux que nous
les mecs on n'est pas foutu de prendre
mais malgré tout ça j'ai intérêt à les
prendre et j'ai même intérêt à les
prendre au niveau économique pour la
performance économique de mon entreprise
dont elle peu de chances que je trouve
tout ça dans la presse dans
l'information puis je suis en couple
oubli ma boîte qui n'existe pas je suis
en coupe je suis hétérosexuel
qu'est ce que je vois dans l'info mal
bon vieux truc du chef de famille c'est
moi le mall là quand même peu de chances
que je vois dans la formation
en fait ce serait peut-être une bonne
idée
geagea et met la main à la pâte à la
maison que je partage un peu un peu au
moins ils partageaient complètement tant
qu'à faire des tâches domestiques avec
ma compagne et que si je fais ça bat
d'abord moi je me sentirai mieux dans
mes baskets mon couple sera plus fort ma
compagne ira mieux
évidemment et puis nos gamins à nos
gamins ils auront un modèle qui sera
vachement plus positifs en fait est que
ce soit des garçons ce soit des filles
ils auront un modèle qui valait
construire ils seront ils seront plus
forts plus forte pour aller affronter
l'avenir
et puis ces gamins on a pas en ce qui me
concerne et ben j'arrive à l'adolescence
chez ma fille puis je vais lui faire un
truc près père de famille ma fille vient
il faut que je te parle
assieds toi dans le canapé témoignage
n'a pas donc il faut que je te parle ma
fille l'information c'est vachement
important puisse sortir tout le monde a
eu sur l'information
pourquoi c'est important et je vais lui
offrir quoi en disant ça c'est quoi les
modèles qu'elle va trouver
elle va trouver quelle peut être une
mère elle va trouver qu'elle peut
s'occuper de la maison la mode
quelques métiers n'est pas beaucoup
alors que ça sacrément créative la
gamine l'information qu'on reçoit
aujourd'hui
d'une part elle est fausse sur le plan
du reflet de la place des hommes
la place des femmes dans le monde dans
lequel nous vivons un problème au niveau
informatif et d'autre part cette
information on propage des stéréotypes
elle les accentue cette information elle
limite nos imaginaires elle nous réduit
le champ des possibles elle nous enferme
bien dans des cases
alors pour les femmes la case est
vraiment bien fermé est tout petit
prière de ne pas en sortir
vous n'êtes pas contents si riquiqui on
n'arrive pas à respirer là dedans
il ya quelques années en fait avec une
association on s'est dit qu'on en avait
marre marre tout ça ça changeait pas ça
bougeait pas les chiffres que je vous ai
donné tout à l'heure sur la dernière
claude de cinq ans a reculé en france
donc on a lancé un magazine on a créé un
magazine ont fait appel à des
journalistes qui ont envie aussi pas
nombreux pas nombreuses mais un mage un
magazine avec journalistes qui ont envie
de montrer autre chose un autre pan de
la réalité cet autre côté du ciel c'est
pas du tout un féminin c'est un magazine
d'information généraliste est donc
réalisée par une association vous
montrer quelque chose
des éléments de ce qu'on peut publier je
pense pas réellement par exemple à razan
zaitouneh en syrie c'était l'ennemi
public numéro un
bachar al assad au départ elle aura fait
voir toutes les couleurs il encourait
après pendant des mois et des mois l
arrivée à transmettre de l'information
partout où combattante extraordinaire
cas j'aime les prix un flingue de sa vie
l'ennemi public numéro un ils l'ont
attrapé on est sans nouvelles d'elle
depuis pas mal de temps elle en prison
jeudi william si un petit peu plus
longtemps
si vous avez déjà entendu ce jour là un
jour jeudi elle rentre dans une
conférence à n'a jamais entendu parler
du sujet comme ça et puis en six ans
elle va réussir à réunir des gens et
puis des gens qui vont faire ce coup
depuis l'institution internationale
avait réalisé avant eux ils vont faire à
titien de ratifier un traité par plus de
120 pays qui va bannir les mines
antipersonnel revenir sur la france et
je veux revenir sur aujourd'hui un sujet
qu'on a publié a pas longtemps un groupe
de femmes qui s'appelle place aux femmes
elles sont dans les quartiers sont à
aubervilliers en banlieue parisienne
thèse en avaient ras-le-bol ne pouvaient
plus rentrer dans un café sans que y'a
que des mecs qui les regardent de la
tête aux pieds sur tout au tout la tête
et qu'il ait des visages elle n'était
pas en sécurité
elles se sont regroupées elles ont créé
un label qu'elles vont toutes ensemble
dans les cafés petit à petit les femmes
reviennent dans les cafés comme beaucoup
par hasard tous cas autour tout ce qui
se passait autour des cafés a commencé à
disparaître
moi j'adore marie dorin sais pas si vous
connaissez ce nom elle a tout raflé ya
pas longtemps aux championnats du monde
de biathlon marie dorin la première fois
qu'elle a été championne du monde à la
fée bingo parce que c'était la première
course internationale
elle gagnait c'était l'an passé elle est
devenue championne du monde
six mois avant à peine six mois avant
elle accouché de son premier enfant
l'anzhi oignies zahia en fait c'est la
seule femme chef d'orchestre en france
est à la tête d'un orchestre de plus de
70 personnes
elle se se produit dans des grandes
salles avec son orchestre et qu'elle
travaille beaucoup également pour que
les jeunes notamment les jeunes des
quartiers populaires puissent accéder à
la musique classique
soizic barthélémy ces derniers exemples
que je vous donnerais tu es une fille
qui est diplômé des plus grandes écoles
de commerce françaises entre à la
société générale de la banque puis est
parti qui a tout arrêté et qui a monté
une ong internationale elle a à peine 27
ans et cette ong balle va dans pas mal
de pays et l'aide des femmes
micro-entrepreneurs pas de conseils à
pas ou plus aucun doute là-dessus toutes
les organisations internationales nous
pondre un rapport toutes les semaines là
dessus le développement viendra dans
tous ces pays en voie de développement
notamment de l'entrepreneuriat des
femmes
on a quelques petits exemples que l'on
retrouve dans ce dans ce magazine
alors je veux pas vous faire croire que
la lecture de ça c'est un coup de
baguette magique on est en train de
parler d'un changement de mentalité
d'envisager le monde autrement de
regarder différemment en ce qui concerne
la place des hommes
la place des femmes dans la société
c'est évidemment du long terme
la journée terminée je suis
photojournaliste tous les reportages que
j'ai fait depuis depuis vingt ans
c'était uniquement des reportages
consacre consacrée à des femmes en lutte
des femmes en mouvement des femmes en
résistance
donc au père au congo en afghanistan etc
en france
évidemment vous pouvez pas savoir tout
ce que j'ai appris avec elle tout ce qu
elle m'en a pris à quel point elles
m'ont fait grandir
c'est quelque chose de 2 c'est
inimaginable j'ai pas de moshe désolé je
pointe pour expliquer un peu tout ça
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'avec
tout ce parcours je me considère
évidemment comme humaniste moindre des
choses
les parois de conséquences quand je dis
humaniste faut que je sois cohérent
évidemment je suis féministe aussi
féministe ça veut dire engagé pour
l'égalité femmes/hommes points
évidemment je suis là dedans je suis en
ce moment avec cette aventure du
magazine famille ciel juste pour
terminer je voudrais juste vous dire
avec tous ces voyages que j'ai faits il
assure que le plus beau le plus
palpitant le plus
keane ou bourges intellectuellement
enfin celui qui me fait vraiment le plus
vibrer c'est vraiment ce voyage là ce
voyage vers cette égalité on obtiendra
peut-être un jour même si je suis poli
on s'en fout mais qu'on obtiendra
peut-être un jour entre les femmes et
les hommes l'égalité pas dans les droits
une égalité dans les fêtes c'est
vraiment le plus chouette des voyages et
tout ça le beau voyage
moi j'ai obtenu grâce à toutes ces
rencontres j'ai obtenu grâce à thèze à
cette information
cette information recueillie transmises
face à l'information que j'ai piqué
aussi à des confrères à des consoeurs
qui ont ramené des choses un peu
différentes
parce que de ce qu'on nous montre en
général dans la formation vous remercie